who's this young fella he looks like
he's a canadian mexican
oh my god what if he is
what up world this is dylan representing
wisco
and now santa monica woke up this
morning and read chuck e cheese change
their name on grubhub
to a name i can't even pronounce and it
got me thinking
what a perfect rat king debate who's a
better rat
chuck e cheese or mickey mouse gang buzz
buzz
now let me be a little biased because
when i was a
young man when i was in eighth grade or
seventh grade
i lived next door to chuck e cheese and
then this gentleman named nathan dunlap
from my high school i decided to murder
everybody in the chuck e cheese
and that's where i used to hang out
really so chuck e cheese
is satan's lair to me i would never step
foot in there again
and it's evil so mickey mouse for the
win
because walt disney and walt disney
world is fantastic
that's nathan dunlap overland high
school
trailblazer alumni dude that guy looks
like nothing dunlap dude
that guy shot up a chuck what year was
that
yeah dude he's on death row well i mean
i remember there's hell
he's doing music now no no no i think
they put him in there
no he's oh he's actually on death row oh
dude yeah i've got him right away
um look dude first of all i'm going to
say the mickey mouse bro
is basically no one has been extorted
more
taken in not extorted that's the wrong
word no one has been taken more
advantage of than mickey mouse
93 i was 10. here's the thing about
mickey mouse though too walt disney
kind of glorified nazi he was a nazi
kind of activist i don't know if people
know that about walt disney really
that's not an eddie bravo conspiracy
that yeah yeah
still makes great cartoons it's a
magical place but
well yeah he had some different hobbies
i mean just talking about cartoons
but bro you don't get one one great
thing without the other that's the thing
give or take there's two sides of the
totter bruh i'm going chuck e cheese
bruh first how
dare you after the story yeah you when
did you go to chucky
you bail out on everybody that dies
brendan okay when did you go to the guy
died in the car at the
tattoo shop he you screw that guy nathan
kaplan or whatever that fucktard's name
was sorry
ftard no that's fine he kills three
people and now you're not going to have
pizza anymore way more than three yeah
no i'm not going back there
they shut it down they turned into a
super salad place
yeah because that's all this was left to
people after he shot him up probably
too much dude sorry hey how how about
also
chuck e cheese some [ __ ] with those
mechanical like plate they're like and
they looked all crazy with their
[ __ ] up eyes they come out every 30
minutes
that was the show they'd have this
[ __ ] trash
pizza the pizza was [ __ ] that's why no
one's buying their pizza to change their
names look at that you know
traumatizing is a young kid look at that
[ __ ] that's chuck there's pasquale put a
little effort into those goddamn dolls
there's munch right there that's munch's
make-believe band that's what they're
called first of all well brendan what
you what you're missing here is the
entrepreneurial spirit
no i'm not dude chuck e cheese was on
[ __ ] meth look at his eyes dude
this was gonna be the next disneyland
okay you don't think this guy had
aspirations you don't think he had a
plan
and then nathan dunlap said hold my
ak-47 yeah and then it's
f tards like nathan dunlap dude who i
hope gets the electric chair
and he walks into the place and shoots
up the entertainment while some kids are
having a birthday
yeah i think he he worked there and they
fired him you try selling bad pizza in
every
trap house neighborhood in america and
see if it ain't hard to do
it's easy to be dizzy mickey mouse when
you got well they started
somewhere dude walt disney didn't start
off [ __ ]
with just a donald trump investment but
he started from nothing
i uh i think walt disney created a
goddamn world
son disney world yeah i've heard of it
what i'm saying is though is that it's
you just you're missing the underdog
spirit man here you got a guy
selling horrible pizza in shitty
neighborhoods people
kids are crying dude yes kids are crying
the place is filled with kovid yeah they
had the ball pit just filled with sars
and [ __ ]
planting a piece of scalp in the ball
pit there one time
and but i'm saying man you're missing
the entrepreneurial spirit i'm going
with chuck cheese's brother
disney you do you get you you get stuck
over there in line there's 700 people in
line
everybody likes disney world it's
freaking so
like hey hey man it's not no it's not
mexico jake
mickey huh
valenzuela was our dad's name ricky what
i'm saying is bro
you get mucked over there it costs you
thousands of dollars to get your
freaking
chubby kid through 900 lines you get
sunburned
sunstroke yeah grandma doesn't give a
[ __ ] dude chuck e cheese is
seven dollars you walk away with sars
bro
huh or you get murdered yeah there's not
been a shooting at disneyland hey you
take a chance let's go to ireland what
do you think man
is chucky cheese real yes it's a real
piece of [ __ ] that's what i mean
literally brendan doesn't know about
business dude it's not a real piece of
[ __ ] it's an up and coming dude i grew
up next to one you [ __ ]
yeah and it was when you went when you
were older it doesn't count
go when you're a kid it's traumatized i
went when i was a kid i was sick to my
stomach and that [ __ ] pizza
and those yeah dude my cousin got his
freaking arm stuck in the back of the
mouse
okay dude disney disneyland does real
work there's actual [ __ ] human beings
in those suits all day
100 degree weather go to disney world
they're sweating they're sweating
human beings bro yes there are but i
will also say it is a
nesting ground for young gay men
who are using drugs and meeting up in
florida and southern california
that's not disneyland behind costumes
to do sex with each other this is a good
part and drugs
chin chime in dude or get out man
yeah man i'm looking at you there and
you just [ __ ] foot through it all okay
you're talking about with your banjo and
your [ __ ]
take a side you mf when i remember going
to chuck e cheese i remember the
the mascot had like a tube coming out of
it and it freaked me out it's called
chords yeah chin cause
yes [ __ ] it's called cut and budget dude
no no it's a third of the people you
want
do you want real cheese but you can't
have both because they were gas powered
in the beginning
that's a show that's a choke on it
that's the only problem bro
you guys haven't it was gas powered and
the fumes ran into the goddamn ball pit
how do you think i turned out so [ __ ]
up man because i spent my summers at
chuck e cheese that was your
no you did that on your own no idea
would drop
us off dude if it drops off me we'd walk
across the street
culture corner what do you guys think
man i can't handle anymore there i feel
i don't know what a keyhole is
i get him in chaos but it looks like e
cheese
dude and i'm down for chocolate cheese
though theo saw it to me
look at him he would definitely be here
he's had a mass murderer and he sold it
one mass murder yeah why don't you take
your baby to frickin disneyland where an
alligator will eat him
no he won't yes he will chin what
happened remember it happened
that happened the dude let the kids swim
in the [ __ ] waters of florida that's
not a disney problem
that's a florida happen in chuck e
cheese
because they can't afford ocean front
property
that's not the part are we right you
can't get moles in the ball pit and then
eating [ __ ] pizza man
chuck e cheese is for [ __ ] terrorists
i'm going to chuck e cheese after this
you need a kid yeah you can't go without
a kid anymore oh really
yeah i'm just fighting with there okay
yeah dude you can't go without a kid
anymore
which is insane it also makes a lot of
sense
well but here's the thing bro yeah
because if you
the last guy that came with that kid
shot everybody in the whole place
dude those are facts you gotta have a
kid man he had a gun and they pretended
the kid was a gun
in a cad shoe around the butt of the of
an ar
and they're like oh that kid's real
skinny i'm not a skinny kid man
imagine you walked into a chuck e cheese
and he's sitting on his own eating a
pizza
yeah that was my summers man
nathan dunlap said no more summers for
you bud
he was saving you from doing something
dark
who's this [ __ ] alley cat thorax cat
what do you think let's get one more
well i grew up in san jose where there
is the biggest chuck e cheese
in the nation and so it was like this
crazy two-story chuck e cheese it was
great
but at the same time i feel like kids
were getting kidnapped left and right
though
yeah it's a sex trafficking scheme yeah
how about business i'm all in on chucky
man [ __ ] y'all you're a bunch of creeps
man anybody who says chuck e cheese is a
goddamn pedophile
you should open oh chuck
[Laughter]
oh let's let the fans debate at what
they say
74 mickey yeah because they're not
[ __ ] pedophiles
i want to i'm with the order of 20.
thank you and i'm going to say one out
of four
fans or listeners chose uh
chuck e cheese's out of respect 75
chose mickey mouse 75 percent
well it's a different amount but i'm out
of four
okay fine here's what we learned
that's because a lot of our propriety go
ahead i'm sorry mark
brendan's a nazi sympathizer that's what
he burns
yeah just because it's possible you guys
are up for mass shooting as long as the
pizza's good
y'all bunch of [ __ ] man bro i can't
even look at you the same
chunky cheese bro i think they can say
that around the kid from aurora
what's wrong with you man i think nathan
left
he's like they're like yeah it's right
down the corner there's a bunch of
people there's a bunch of people
that are dressed shittily eating pizza
inside i
bet he was trying to go into your home
bro
that's [ __ ] up you need to look up the
case it was after hours he got fired and
shot all the employees did he really
damn you're a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
hate that kind of stuff have you ever
ever bought the nazis of thornton
brandon
not to not in america not to [ __ ]
disney world and the nazis did it on a
bigger scale basically the nazis are
nathan dunlap but more a larger group
that's why that's why you have to go
with you hit me with this young looking
thor up here
yeah get me with this thought
[Music]
is